there's a great article by Eric Sasson
in the New Republic which points out
something that I've been talking about
with you guys since November 8th but
especially since January 20th and what
I've been telling you is that it's great
that there's mobilization and activation
of more voters and new people as a
result of the disaster that is the
Donald Trump administration the entire
resist thing is important it's great
it's valuable and progresses need to
resist Trump's absurdity at every
opportunity that there is but
progressives and especially from a sort
of electoral perspective House and
Senate Democrats need to do more than
just resist they actually need a
progressive platform to push and resist
with and fastened points this out
astutely in his article where he says
quote progressives have fallen into a
familiar pattern early in donald trump's
presidency wait for him to screw up and
then depending on the severity of the
offense react with mockery or outrage
this applies to the trivial as when
Trump tweeted despite the negative press
cops buffet and to the consequential as
when he withdrew the United States last
week from the Paris climate agreement
Trump's disaster after disaster
embarrassment after embarrassment
scandal after scandal it's created an
environment for serious criticism from
the left but progressives and Democrats
do need a plan
to unify people around voting for
something in 2018 and in 2020 not just
against Trump we know that just doing
the were against the incumbent thing
isn't hugely effective look at george w
bush's reelection in 2004 george w
bush's approval rating in the last month
or so before the 2004 election was as
low as 47% and he won and yes maybe it
was partially because of strange
electoral stuff in Ohio where he ended
up winning by a hundred and 18,000 votes
but still it came down to just Ohio and
he did win there by by that margin or
close to it if you believe that there
was foul play there so Democrats need a
progressive message and a few issues to
make their issues and rallying and
holding signs is great and it's fine if
it gets people involved but it's not
going to win elections right that's from
the voters point of
view and opposing Trump when he does
crazy things is all well and good for
House and Senate Democrats but you need
specific issues that will get people
active and I hope that Democrats will
take this seriously Pat yeah I think the
issue with going to anti Trump is that
what if the Trump Russia investigations
come back negative and there's no proof
of collusion sure what if his approval
ratings stay north of 40% and the stock
market continues to do well economy too
continues to do regular relatively well
you have to be able to have something
that you can go on the offensive with
not only that if the Trump Russia thing
implodes and Trump is actually impeached
now you don't even have Trump to run
against in 2018 or 2020 so I believe the
issues for progressives and ideally
Democrats should be there's overlap in
progressives and Democrats but it's not
a hundred percent as I'm sure you know
health care single most important issue
to Americans according to the most
recent Gallup most important problem
poll health care for all should be the
message now careful when I say that I
don't necessarily mean single-payer
government-run health care that's what I
would love that's maybe too specific and
a non-starter politically at this point
but health care for all as in something
for everyone some basic level of care
for everybody
100% coverage that is affordable and
that actually covers you okay number 2
save the planet
get away from global warming
specifically and even go beyond climate
change craft a message on the
environment that is not as much science
versus non science although that's
accurate right but we know that it
doesn't really convince people couch it
as patriotic and a moral duty and an
economic duty right when it comes to the
jobs of the future make it an economic
reality when we talk about the
environment combined with that second
most of you can combine both environment
and jobs because jobs is the second most
important problem according to the
Gallup most important problem poll so I
think those are the should be the top
two calling card issues for all
progressives and Democrats to unite on
you really do have to hone in on a few
issues that will pull well among the
American public and that might
in putting things like gun control and
the death penalty on the back burner
bill scher talked to us about that he
said you know strategically it might
make sense for Democrats not to really
be talking about gun control as much and
to pick a third issue there's a sort of
amalgam of a few issues that are
important to people based on that Gallup
poll immigration race relations national
security and international issues
altogether there needs to be a sort of
united front on these issues from the
left it's more complex but it can't be
the brand of identity politics that have
criticized that doesn't work it can't
ignore the obvious problem of the impact
of radical Islamic terror in the West
sort of in the model of Saudi Wahhabism
and Isis immigration it can't be a
xenophobic version of quote fixing
immigration it needs to make sense this
is sort of a topic in and of itself but
progresses need a unified plan there and
that's going to be difficult I think
because of some of the fracturing on the
left on that issue and I think we've
already learned this lesson through
Hillary Clinton because in the last few
months of her campaign she focused a lot
more on Trump's temperament his
readiness to lead on how he treats women
and you know those sound like winning
points but if you're not going on the
offensive if you don't have a
overwhelmingly populist economic message
you're not going to win those Rust Belt
states and to not be overly critical of
progressives and Democrats as Pat sort
of builds the critique there the
paradigm of American politics is and has
been contrarian ism right go against
those in power if you're out of power
there needs to be a change you lost to
Donald Trump and yes preventing the DNC
from messing with the primary ever again
the way it did in 2016 is also important
that's a whole other conversation maybe
rounded out with ending the war on drugs
and maybe a $15 minimum wage